joining me now is the journalist who
obtained all of those Disney videos
Chris Ruffo Manhattan institute's senior
fellow also joining me is amla equinobi
prageru personality former left-wing
activist all right Chris you are
speaking of thorns in the side of these
woke corporations
um Disney went on to write that the only
option for corporate leaders is to stand
tall for authenticity generosity joy and
decency these things are Kryptonite for
the right-wing agenda fortunately they
are also the heart and soul of the
Disney brand well
everyone counts except you know all of
these kind of moderate Americans who
just want to go and have fun and not be
proselytized to or not have their kids
turned into you know sexual uh you know
points of perversion for teachers your
reaction to this
yeah I mean it really is the case that
Disney claims to be standing tall but
you saw the video CEO Bob chapek someone
who earns 32.5 million dollars a year as
his base salary uh is just absolutely
degrading himself every day day in and
day out and the reality is is that the
conservatives in this country have dealt
a major blow to Walt Disney in Florida
legislators are looking at taking away
their special tax breaks in Congress and
D.C conservatives had said we're not
going to extend the Disney copyrights
for Mickey Mouse and other characters
that are set to expire next year that's
a multi-billion dollar hit against the
company and conservative parents and
families all over this country are in
revolt against the mouse because they
don't want their kids to be an
experimental ground for the kind of
sexual engineering of children that is
clearly Disney's Gambit we've seen it in
the clips we've seen the kind of a
bizarre personalities that are at the
helm whether it's a biromantic asexual a
bunch of they thems what whatever the
neo-sexual identities might be those are
the people who are calling the shots
they're projecting their own kind of
bizarre psychology onto the CEO who just
backs down every day
now as I said they're targeting your
generation your gen Z right
right I am I hate all the names I hate
the names of the generations they're all
stupid but they're so dumb but they're
they admit that's the group they're
after my point is most of the Gen seers
aren't going to pay 300 bucks for
whatever it costs for a park hopper pass
I'm going to pay that their parents or
their grandparents pay it and they're
not going to want to foot these bills
your reactions oh exactly
yeah I completely agree with you I think
what their motive here is is to get
children while they're young and
infiltrate their minds with this sort of
ideology because they know that if they
get these children at a young age it
will stick as it did with me when I was
a young leftist that stuck with me into
young adulthood so that is really the
goal here I think what they failed to
recognize is the power of parents and
that parents are really awake to the
indoctrination that they're trying to
push on their children we're seeing them
protest at Disney we're seeing them
cancel their Disney plus subscriptions
and they are sending letters to these
Executives saying I will not tolerate
you thinking that you are the parent of
my child and that you get to dictate
what my child learns and we're seeing
the horrific outcomes of children
learning this sort of gender Theory not
just uh here on Disney but in school and
in mainstream media and social media
it's devastating
well Pete I want to get to one more of
the videos but before we do that Pete
butterjudge revealed his thoughts guys
on the Florida Bill and he did this this
morning watch
your husband chaston he's been a vocal
critic of what's going on in my state of
Florida when the with the so-called
don't say gay law now
um which he says will kill kids do you
agree he's right and and I think every
law to be judged for the effect it's
going to have on real people this is
going to hurt people
well Chris it's the opposite this bill
protects children's innocence if it
still matters to any of these people
yeah I mean the logic here is is so
stunning it's almost to the point of
total absurdity uh the idea that if you
can't teach kindergarteners
five-year-olds about uh that they might
be pansexual or asexual or biromantic or
all of these other new identities that
somehow it's going to be a leading to
killing them one of the Disney activist
Partners actually said that this was all
a scheme by Republicans to start
kidnapping children the rhetoric is
going to the point of insanity
conservatives have to just sit strong
not give up and keep fighting against
these baseless and ridiculous smears now
Chris you've done such a service to
parents across this country to reveal
what's really going on at Disney and
amla just for our the edification of our
viewers there's what one Disney producer
wants to include in the shows she's
involved with watch
I identify as like a biromantic asexual
I want to use my content to like go
deeper I want to like add the pox the
the pockets of the lgbtq community That
You Don't See I was like I want to get
like day in advance
I think she said like three or four
times in the span of about 20 seconds
how about it we like stop saying like
amla reaction quickly right yeah clearly
she should be at the head of teaching
children it's amazing how many
identities they come up with and there
will be more and it shows you how
important things like like sex and race
and gender are to these people when we
should be focusing on moral character
integrity and values that's what Disney
used to do with their stronghold on the
American Childhood they need to go back
to that
Chris Amala great to see you both
tonight thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else